Jamie Foxx does not want to talk about  Katie Holmes like some real loving  basketball the 50 year old actor walked  off a live interview on Friday during  ESPN's SportsCenter after being asked  about his rumored girlfriend there  during the broadcast I saw pictures the  [ __ ] Katie Holmes played basketball  for Valentine's Day like some real love  in basketball game we lose jamie was  gearing up to play in the NBA all-star  Celebrity game when he was questioned  about his rumored ladylove the pair have  been romantically linked for years and  have made a few rare public appearances  together recently including their  basketball date on Valentine's Day it  was really a lot of fun I'm ready mate  all you got to do is add water so  they're gonna pull some water on me I'm  ready to rock but all seemed well back  on the court as Jamie let another  reporter in on his last thoughts  alongside opponent Justin Bieber before  the game let's have some fun out there  [Music]